Jim Nantz has been covering the Masters
for CBS Sports for 32 consecutive years
he is with us from Augusta Jim good
morning great to see you
good morning always great to be with all
of you never seen anything on that first
tee like the raw emotion you just
watched as Arnold Palmer was certainly
remembered in such a grand and beautiful
fashion and Billy Payne did such a great
job I think of summing it all up and at
the same time getting this tournament
started with the Gary Player and Jack
Nicklaus hitting those first shots it
was it was and there's a lot of news too
as we begin the Masters first the number
one golfer Justin Johnson had an
accident what's the latest he slipped on
a staircase last night that the house
he's running and he threw his back out
so fortunately for Dustin he has the
last starting time today just a little
after 2 o'clock and we really won't know
probably until a half hour before that
start time if if Dustin is going to be
able to apply it's just a shame he comes
in here having won his last three starts
including two World Golf Championships
he was the favored coming in and just a
bizarre twist of events here on the eve
of the tournament yes do you know what
happened Jim he was in he was in he was
just going downstairs you know he's he's
got a little one running around the
house and I know he was going downstairs
in this rental house and he had he had
only socks on his feet so I just you
know we've all done that before done
that before
he slipped in the jordiz bagging Jim
trial here hey Charlie how are you I'm
well excited to be here
what storylines are you looking at for
this Matthew you know this is going to
be first off today's going to be a big
storyline as you can no doubt tell with
the winds it's it's it's it's cold and
it's blowing up to almost 40 mile an
hour gust it's going to be a survival
test out there today I mean you could
shoot a really high score but we come in
looking at
jordan Spieth trying to avenge what
happened last true and had the big lead
with nine holes to go and made a seven
on the 12th low with quadruple bogey you
got Rory McIlroy going for the career
Grand Slam
and then you got the Dustin Johnson
story that we talked about so everybody
comes here primed and hopefully we're
gonna have a suspenseful finish on
Sunday it's great to see you yeah thank
you all great to see you it's great to
watch you it's always great to watch the
Gulf and it's great to listen to Jim
Nantz yeah you going Charlie looking for
it I would love to thinking about it
okay thanks again Jim are you can stream
CBS Sports coverage of the entire 81st
masters tournament starting this morning
on CBS sports.com and CBS Sports will
broadcast the action starting Saturday
at 3:00 Eastern right here on CBS and
right after the break our conversation
with Julia Roberts be right back